on the court black night of March 31st
2007 my mother and I scrambled down the
steep rocky bank of the frozen Yellow
River which divides North Korea and
China there were patterns above us and
below and guard post 100 yards on the
either side of us mended by soldiers
ready to shoot onion attempting to cross
the border we had no idea why would come
last I was 13 years old but we were
desperate to get to China where there
might be a chance to survive the young
North Korean smuggler who was guiding us
across the border
insisting we had to go that night he had
to pay some guards to look the other way
I followed him in the darkness but I was
so unsteady that I had to scoot down the
bank on my bottom the next small
avalanches of rocks crashing ahead of me
our guide you made a phone call to
someone on the other side the Chinese
side and then you whispered one
hi I'm Todd crane for reason TV I'm here
with you and me Park she is the author
of in order to live a North Korean
girl's journey to freedom
welcome to Reason TV hi hi thank you so
much for having me you grew up at the
time you grew up the years I was a
really historical moment in North Korean
history if I'll just following the
collapse of the Soviet Union there were
it was famine widespread and I was
wondering can you talk a little bit
about that could you talk a little bit
about the what life in general was like
in North Korea when you were growing up
my life was a kind of roller coaster
when there's time my father in a party
so he could able to feed us properly so
I had three meals a day and there was a
time where I didn't have much things to
eat and but beyond that the life in
North Korea
the ceilings seeing that the bodies on
the streets and seeing hungry children
on the streets and that was very normal
life for me and I never thought that was
weird or that was sad day and your
father had a sort of a mid-level job in
the government officially that was his
official job he had a kind of yeah
official job for a very short amount of
time but he could not be there because
of his porcelain which is social caste
system and he worked in the bottom and
working the black mark and mostly what
did he do in the black market to make
ends meet in the beginning he sold
everything he saw the cigarette so she
he bought he bought the cigarette in the
border area and implemented inner the
country so he could make it profit out
of it and he was caught and arrested for
this what how was he caught and what was
his punishment what happened to him we
didn't know that what he his sentence
was we didn't know what was Trier was
but in North Korea the calm just arrest
them tortured on them and send a prison
and the family member didn't even get in
why for the Trier how long was he in
prison he went send it to one year labor
camp and he went to labor camp for 10
years so total of 11 years of sentence
and he served three years old and was
that your motivation for leaving North
Korea's that was that what you said we
gotta go or when your families yeah
think it was the kind of biggest
motivation because once my father became
prisoner I was also marked as a pre
criminal in that society because my
father's crime is my crime and therefore
my brother
painted in that society and but you
didn't know what's on the outside right
you don't know what's outside North
Korea so how do you know it's going to
be better in another country when I was
in North Korea I saw also the media's
and then I watched
Chinese movies and how Chinese
advertisement and there I saw fat kids
and people were look big and they had
lots of food and they were advertisement
in North Korea we don't have
advertisement for the people we don't
have anything to size that the
propaganda and I and her so I live in
the northern part of North Korea so I
could see the lights from tongue why the
China side and I will I was always
wondered what the lights why we don't
have lights in North Korea but why China
has lights and I believe somehow if I go
to China then they might have enough
food for me to eat it's interesting that
advertising did it to you too as well
in in in in the West we kind of
disregard advertising as having no value
right no regime value but to you you you
actually say today was an important to
me was because I could not believe with
something talks about rather than the in
rather than the regime and that the
propaganda and I remember when I was
doing my watched advertisement about the
mirek and I didn't know milk was coming
from cow I never had
so I wondered what that taste would be
like the liquid thing is white not pure
like water so what that it would be and
that was I think to me that was freedom
they were creatively trying to sell
their products and they can say anything
about it by North Korea
everything was propaganda so that
advertisement to me something was
revolutionary thing and you freedom the
idea of freedom and food I didn't know
what freedom was I didn't even know the
word I didn't know the concept I never
heard about the world freedom to me was
the happiest thing to me was having food
and when I was young I never dreamed for
being a president or prime minister my
dream was having a Wang Bacharach breath
breath and that's all I dreamed so can
you tell us just briefly about the
crossing over mountains and rivers so
once my father got out from the sick
place so he was very sick and he got out
from the prison to get the treatment and
my family went really hungry
we ate frozen potatoes grasshoppers and
he could not fed us in North Korea so my
sister left with her friend first and my
mother and I were trying to find her but
when we found the lady that my sister
left a note that find this lady and I
went found her and then I told her that
I want to go to China too and somehow
for some reason she said I can help you
that hae-sun in the border area but if
we cannot just cause anywhere because
the polio guy is watching us and they
will assure us so we had to go to cross
the mountain or like big hair and then
we went to cross the frozen river and I
will be bribe the border guards but we
didn't little man who was helping us
bribe the guards but we cannot bribe
every guards because 100 meters guards
guards guards and at all was like
barking so somebody who would shoot us
from there
in this guy's body so it was very scary
I thought I was gonna be shot and it's
not like once you get into China
everything is great right everything is
actually really hard once you get into
China and once I know you had a lot of
hard hardships there but once you get
your bearings in China then what what do
you do it our groups typically helped by
missionary groups or Christian groups or
do the people that's what I hear
sometimes or did the people of China
come to your help what happens once you
get there and you realize you have to
eat you have to live I didn't know I was
coming and I was 13 years old and when I
got there the first thing I saw was my
mother awake and the guy who took us to
China was human trafficker and he
tricked us so when you arrived in China
the border Chinese the Korean ethnic
Chinese man was waiting for us and then
he was trying to rape me and my mother
protected me from there and then we
found out that if we went to stay in
China we have to be soared in last thing
we can't go back to North Korea but that
means if I go back North Korea will be
imprisoned or dying from the starvation
or disease so I cannot go back and sue
so how do you survive and what is your
goal where are you trying to go at this
point
I didn't escape for freedom I didn't
escape or or anything like that I
escaped for bottle wise North Korea is
so hard and you don't think too much you
just want to survive and we just crossed
the river and then we got there that
they say if you're not live in China you
gotta be sword
and you have to get married to a Chinese
farmer and if you don't want you can go
back but I know I'm gonna die I'm going
back North Korea so my mother was a
being sorta for a farmer and her price
of $65 at the beginning and I was also
sort of for 20
dollars and we were both separated from
that moment but at some point you
decided to cross into to make it to
Mongolia which closed yeah after two
years of living in China hiding and that
during that time the man who bought me
he offered me a deal that if I become
his mistress he will bring my mother in
he would bring my father from North
Korea so I accepted a deal from him so I
became his mistress and my father came
to China but he had a untreated colon
cancer so he passed away so I had to
bury his ashes in the middle mountain
and then after two years the man who
bore me for some reason he let me go so
my mother and I was free and then we met
Chinese missionaries no the Christian
missionaries in China and they told us
how we can go to South Korea and all
this time are you still hope you don't
know where your sister is
you still have hoped you may reunite
with her that you may find her yeah I
saw I started okay I was still looking
for her and I was still hoping she where
she would be
you caught you cross through the Gobi
Desert yeah you talk about them it was
2009 and somebody told me if you go to
South Korea
you will be free you can your Chin's
which I'm wearing today you can dye your
hair and you can watch movies without
getting arrested and at the wall that is
great and that's so cool
to media towers freedom not the freedom
of expression freedom of speech that we
are talking about in this country and
then five we do five people in our team
we walked and crossed the copy desert in
the freezing winter night and we follow
the compass and then later recognize
compass so we follow the Stars north and
chill freedom so for those of us who
have never been to the Gobi Desert which
is almost all of us just paint a little
picture what is the Gobi Desert like
when you're not just going there as a
tour
you're actually going there to survive
so I heard the what's bettered there's a
lots of Sunday's gonna be there
and the moment I was stood on the desert
nothing just nothing Sun just ray and
it's Angelus Angelus space and I felt
only the stars are with me and I
threatened this even earth this universe
abandoned us and where do you where were
you even had it in the Gobi Desert
they say they told us if we had a
compass so if you go to north and like
west between north and west follow there
and if you go straight straight straight
and if you crossed all eight or
something like wire fences that will be
mongolian territory then you have to
find the Mongolian soldiers or Mongolian
people and tell them you want to go to
South Korea go from North Korea so we
were crossing the wire fences and you're
calling and walking and warning but it
was 2009 and it was end of February or
beginning of March so it was freezing
cold and you did reach the border at one
point and you did Galla stood guard you
got arrested us and and so how do you
how do you deal with that yeah when I
almost did the Gaza was region gone I
can't point in me free hands up hands up
and I was so so thankful because I miss
somebody in the desert thank you thank I
was big in Chinese they say so
and they're like no no you are gonna go
to China and we were like surprised
because you thought we go to Mongolia
they were save us but they were saying
they were sent us back to China and
called North Korea so we had like
begging them in return if you send us
back we will kill ourselves because we
were ready to kill ourselves
we brought the lasers we brought poisons
and we were ready to kill ourselves if
we are going to be some mad North Korea
and they didn't send us back and they
Prosecco
kind of prison kind of some camp for a
several month and then we flew to South
Korea this is your first taste of a
wealthy country and I'm wondering what
is your first what is your first
experience of that what do you think of
that everything was a shining everything
was shining and I went to bathroom and I
couldn't believe because they had a
toilet paper and he had a like flower
print Tony and the smell was so good but
oh I don't want to use that for that
purpose it's so fancy and I stole a baby
to me and I just cannot believe because
people were wearing the girls like young
girls wearing like a miniskirt they're
having like a small thing with their
hands which is cell phone and everybody
was so fun just like the advertisements
that yeah it was it when you saw it it
was like this is like television that I
remember yeah or maybe in fancier than
that really because yeah I didn't think
that was really what I saw in TV because
in North Korea everything on TV is lying
so I thought also maybe in the West it
won't to be right something's lying not
that your life is not going to be like
that in the real life people not gonna
have a Nobu people not gonna have a car
you know only in Kiwi people are having
it like North Korea but here reality was
like a TV how were you able to reunite
with your sister more than a year ago
she came to South Korea and then she
found us at the NSC the National
Intelligence Center what is that what is
the National Intelligence Center they
investigate you if you're a spy or not
and then because they had to check every
your background and I registered what
who's my sister was my father
where I did grow up and my sister do the
same thing and they like so oh this
matches and do have your mother name is
this your sister name is this and they
contacted us and what was that day like
when you first when you saw your sister
again hey I had no idea there
and I got a phone call from my mother
and she was crying and your sisters here
but there was lots of times people were
tricked us and they asked us money for
that I thought it was another thing like
that so I didn't trust like what do you
mean my sister's here and it was this
interior I was just screaming I cannot
believe that I was really happening so a
couple of years ago I interviewed
another famous North Korean defector by
the name of shin dong-hyuk you know who
is a friend of yours yes well I was born
in a political prison camp in North
Korea I was expected to just do manual
labor and to work and I had no concept I
had no rights I had no concept of what
the human rights were I was destined to
live and die in this prison camp the
North Korean government came after him
and really hard they tried to discredit
everything he said they tried to
humiliate him and embarrass him
nationally and I'm wondering are you
prepared for that you say that the North
Korean government has come after you a
little bit they came up to me more than
that don't tell me about that I have
told my story many times and I was not
perfect and I was hiding a secret for
the first time I wrote down this horror
story that I was trafficked I was raped
at the age of 13 and it was really hard
for me as a girl who I have dream I want
to be on the more some day I want to
have family I want her baby that's my
dream but I thought you fired me what
had happened to me I thought nobody was
going to see me as a normal person
especially in Asia tradition the purity
virginity as a woman is everything and
to me I thought if I reveal that it's
gonna be the end of the world I were
forever a ruse just to be normal again
so I was hiding my secret ally
but North Korean government came after
me and they described me that I didn't
suffering in North Korea and also they
said my father died in North Korea not
in China and they say my mother I was a
very ambitious girl because he knows
gripping ambitious extremely bad thing
and they say you're an ambitious girl
and your father was bad person and your
mom was immoral person
as you can see both puck and her mother
have it made it that they have no idea
what they're talking about the human
rights situation in North Korea this
clearly proves that their scripts are
written by the US and its followers but
they didn't really come up with like a
big thing except my father died in North
Korea and my father's ashes wounded were
in China and my mother went to China a
few months ago and he bought my father's
ashes to South Korea so basically our
whole family follow us in freedom now so
they aren't very totally ready for it in
my story is like I'm talking about the
executions and the governor letting
people to see also the media's and the
starvation it's not I'm only testifying
it there are hundreds of million people
say the same thing and we consider from
the satellite there is concentration
camp there is starvation and the North
Korean regime is top really they really
offers people and that's what this
regime against me they say I'm the Papa
Rob CIA
I'm the human propaganda pipette and I
think a last week I spoke to action in
at the United Nations in Geneva and the
Austrian diplomats were there too and I
told my story in from all over the world
and they also say I'm fake because it
was training me to be this way so I
don't know how much we should give
credit to this evil regime I don't know
how much that is worth pay our attention
to pay for that and I of the media was
not perfect and my English as you can
see is my other language it's not in my
first language so sometimes the
journalist unintentionally misunderstand
me and they write down something they
write down different dates and it's out
of my control because I'm not the one
who's writing the article so I think I'm
afraid inevitably I might make the
mistake in the future with my land
favor but I know that the truth
governor's create oppression and they
are tragedy it cannot be silenced
there's no doubt about that that it
cannot be silenced and you make a very
good point so the questions then why why
have like mr. Shin and a few others they
have embellished their stories it's
absolutely true that they suffered
terribly that for example mr. Shin was
did grow up in a concentration camp but
it wasn't the one that he said it was
and some of the things in his life
weren't as bad as he said he were he
were
why why if things are already that bad
and I believe they are
why embellish why do some of them why do
some defectors do that I don't know to
me the reality is already bad I can even
describe what life is in North Korea is
on this squad boo it's unimaginable
there is no way I can even tell you how
different the North Korea's it's
different universe it's different planet
I can even tell you the reality the
truth how can I come up with something
different and I don't know what other
people's story because I might I don't
know they might have reasons like myself
I had a reason to hide my secret I
didn't want told me I was raped when I
was 13 years old I don't know their
reason but I only know my reason why
that had happened to me and so yeah but
it's very sad tuition yeah I don't know
I mean I speculate that sometimes I
think some people are understandably
angry at North Korea and they want to
make it even were to make it seem even
even worse than it is if that's possible
yeah because in my case my case is like
I have lots of witnesses if we have read
my book so we have all the recordings
that my court for who worked with me and
who had this a scary to me
and who met all the ladies who escaped
together with me and as my friend the
young DA who I met in South Korea who I
grew up it together for
made the paper doors reading me and
because of that I there's no way my
story can be verified in every way and
we already have lots of recordings from
that and the witnesses there I often
learned that when North Korean defectors
moved to Seoul or South Korea they're
not actually treated well by South
Koreans and what that's fascinating to
me too and I don't understand why that
is I remember the very first day when I
got out from the resettlement centre so
there is a resentment in South Korea and
they teaches what is it a machine
what's bank but credit cards what the
election is and I remember they taught
us how to charge money in the
transportation card and I thought
Monique goes into that card and there
was money money disappears I like I said
magic I'm kind of like that way with my
laundry machine yes so that's how I
learn and of course I didn't know what I
was like a full paper is I don't know
what's coffee copy machine it I don't
know what americano is so I can know
even like a computer like five years
baby I knew like less than the babies
yeah
but in South Korean society they view as
like in a general sense like a less than
them and they see us like we are less
educated and we don't have a good
understanding of capitalism and
democracy anniversary we are from
communism country where the government
telling us what to do and we don't
really think for our serve and we don't
work hard therefore so these kind of
stereotypes against the people from
communism backwards were there and it
was extremely hard for me because I
wanted to start in your life but before
even I start they were telling your
loser already you are stupid you are
dumb you are not gonna be succeed in the
society so that's why I was holding into
the books that the books all inter told
me that I can do I would think that
anyone who can survive in the North
Korean black market would actually be a
very good entrepreneur and have the kind
of skills that would allow you
to succeed in a capitalist world that's
is it true that is debatable that's
debatable
yes because uh I did the pro market
business too when I was 11 years old I
saw the persimmons in the market but I
don't have any entrepreneur here really
I see I'm surprised to hear that because
you're kind of a media personality and a
media star you're on television a lot in
South Korea or you have been you
certainly have a big social media
presence you're you're you're good
salesperson no I I am yeah so I think
I'm sure in North crater so people have
to find the only way to survive and that
is driving in Earth's Kurtis young
generation evolving in this unique way
they finally started thinking for
themselves in North Korea which were not
allowed in North Korea because a
government providing them food but the
people know they don't need a food from
the government and this kind of gives
them some freedom independence from the
government and people can think for
themselves finally and this trading
given this opportunity to learn about
the capitalism and the trading and so
I'm very positive and very optimistic
that these young people in North Korea
they will drive and more and more and
they were bringing a change in their
country what do you think about
Americans and people from the West
visiting North Korea as tourists this is
happening more and more now as a North
Korean defector to me and I was not
elated
I was norske I was now swinging up and
going to restaurant donors or having a
pizza right I was starving and eating
the Dragonfly it's eating the plants and
that was my life and I remember how my
father tortured and my father died
without knowing even this kind of
democracy exists in the world he didn't
even know this much food was available
in the world and if I had things that
Americans throw away
I would never escape
Korea that's how much we were desperate
and I was raped even after 10 years
because I was born North Korea I have
nothing going wrong in the world I was
my crime was just being inborn North
Korea
and so many people going through this
now and to me personally when the people
pay money and go there and they believe
any kind of exchange is great and this
will help the people inside North Korea
and to me is like you are going to see
the part that only governments want you
to see right it's kind of your vision
Kim Jong Un's yard and CI so North Korea
so some people they misunderstand North
Korean they say I saw amazing things
people happy there they have lots of
food but some people they learn the
oppression and they see how much freedom
is not there they see the suffering from
people and they raise more and as once
they go to North Korea so I don't think
is this is black and white issue the
name of the book is in order to live a
North Korean girl's journey to freedom
I've been here talking with you me Park
thanks for talking Thank You solid rock
my pleasure I'm Todd crane and for
reason TV
you